Remains the fide women's world champion
the score was tied going into Game 12 of
the world championship match so a win
for either player would secure the title
The defending Champion Zhu ambitiously
opted for an imbalanced game trading her
rook and a pawn for two of Lei Ting
jae's minor pieces the double question
mark which is a critically bad move this
was an equal trade on paper but the
imbalanced nature meant Anything Could
Happen Jews Knights ruled the center of
the board and once lays weak C and D
pawns fell it spelled the beginning of
the end after careful maneuvering
eventually Zhu was able to use her
knights in assisting the unimpeded
promotion of a pawn these Heavens on the
border and on move 62 play resigned as a
result